i can't imagine having a film broken out
by frames
they took advantage of the entire medium
every single one of his movies is a
masterpiece so you're saying that this
is a fx animation
today's episode is brought to you by
draftkings hey everyone welcome back to
another episode
of animators react we are joined today
by eric koenig who has worked on a bunch
of stuff from the simpsons
some classic warner brothers films he's
incredibly talented he's been in the
industry for a long time and has some
awesome insights to share with us
on animation what is your job
specifically so i
am in charge of special projects things
like commercials or promos
we've done trump cartoons over the last
few years you guys probably don't use
like pen and paper much anymore do you
use it mostly like tablets and
so when i first started i still did the
paper animation with the pegs on it and
then it was around that time
that we switched over to the wacom
tablet and you draw
right directly onto the screen i use it
for editing it's the it's the best
yeah there's so much stuff to pick apart
so let's jump right in
we'll kick things off here with fantasia
let's talk about the idea of animation
is art that was the idea behind fantasia
was that
it incorporates music and dance and
theater and filmmaking and color and
painting
all into these films and what walt
disney was trying to do
was go we are making an art piece
[Music]
you know i love fantasia but i also
think he got
a little wrapped up in his
pretentiousness with fantasia there's
some sequences
like night on ball mountain which i just
love and it scared the bejesus out of me
when i was a kid
and then there's other sequences that
tiptoe on the boring side
it was a lesson for walt that he
primarily is an
entertainer that he has a duty to the
audience to keep them entertained
fantasia has a mastery of effects
animation there's a beautiful sequence
with the pedal drops in the water
[Music]
so you're saying that this is a fx
animation there's kind of two
animators that get employed at a studio
there's the character animators and the
effects animators
characters are characters the effects
animators
are water fire
in this case petal droplets it is its
own
mastery these people are geniuses the
good effects animator also it's a
mixture of
being well observed looking at realistic
things like bubbles here in this case
then you have to take those effects and
you have to make them work
in the world that you're creating so if
it's fantasia there's a style of the
effects that works for this sequence if
it's a movie like prince of egypt
there's an egyptian flair to those
effects
i remember seeing tests on a movie i
worked on called the road el dorado and
they would
incorporate mayan designs into the fire
that's awesome yeah and and you know i
can't sing the praise of these guys
enough i'll miss you
your best friend
it's your hero we're almost there so any
discussion about animation would be
completely fraught without talking about
miyazaki
a true genius master draftsman and the
master storyteller
you know he storyboards all of his own
films so these are
we're looking at actual his drawings and
the thing that's fun to look at
they're loose but everything is there
the weight
the storytelling the caricature every
drawing that he does
has that in it my first film i saw of
miyazaki's was
nausicaa of the valley of the wind i was
so amazed by the storytelling and the
design of all the creatures the big
change that kind of came along with him
was incorporating modern cinema
into animation so you have camera moves
camera pans 360 spins all the things
that a live
action filmmaker will use he was using
in his animation
he's one of my favorite directors and
creators of
entertainment and media of all time you
know every single one of his movies is a
masterpiece
i love how you combine it with american
cinema you certainly have the american
storytelling
but at the same time he's not afraid to
slow down and like show things that are
just kind of boring and mundane
there's that beautiful scene on the
train when they're leaving the bath
house and they're just
sitting on that train you know and their
whole movie just stops
and takes a deep sigh
[Music]
well you know you cry it's just gorgeous
would you say this is a mix of space and
reality versus
goofy and cartoony it's a beautiful mix
of both all of this stuff has a
caricature to it
they're grounded in realism but then he
caricatures the faces and the
expressions
his characters are just the best yeah
everyone
is so well-rounded and everyone has
heart and everyone has
like a purpose and you love every
character throughout the entire
process you learn to love everybody hey
if eric is cool enough to subscribe to
us
you can be that cool too consider
subscribing to the corridor crew
now let's take a look at something that
you worked on cats don't dance
i was right out of cal arts right out of
college when i got the chance to work on
this movie
it was really made with a tiny crew with
a really shoestring budget the fun part
of it was was that
there were only maybe 20 to 25 animators
as opposed to the normal 60 that's on a
disney movie
and so we were all given a lot of
responsibility too much responsibility
at an early age got a little cocky
you know and later on in my career had
to take a step back
i got rhythm in my feet
what specifically were you doing here
for this piece so i
am animating the elephant there's a goat
and a fish
this is a scene i animated actually got
to mix cg animation with hand-drawn
animation here which is pretty early at
that time the piano with cg
so you mentioned that there is a cg
piano a very well animated piano with
perspective shifts it's super smooth
it's mathematically precise so it's you
know it's a 3d model
but when we came out in 1996 so that's
pretty early was
having cg like cell shaded cg was that
prevalent before this or is this one of
those first times
it had to be 10 years before tron is the
big milestone in cg animation
by the time we're getting there cg
animation is actually
used a lot more at the time what we used
it for were
inanimate objects like cars or in this
case as a piano
that would be nearly impossible to draw
by hand
because you would have to try and draw
all of that perspective shift the thing
that strikes me about this piano
sequence
is i see this a lot in futurama like the
ships and like the
other objects that are inanimate that
aren't moving there'll be a 3d model
that looks
cg and it seems like it's a smart use of
your time and effort because the piano
is just the piano it doesn't stretch
doesn't squash it's not doing anything
it just has to move because the camera's
moving so by making that a 3d object
you're saving yourself the hassle of
just kind of doing grunt work of a
shifting perspective and you're putting
all of your attention and energy
into a character instead
now how did it line up to the music with
a musical the
musical numbers are usually always some
of the first things that are written
in an animated film because you have to
animate to the music on the x sheet are
little x's that mark the beats
of the music okay okay so i know on
frame 16
down and then on frame 18 or whatever
it's up
and then crazy i have a recording of in
the old days it was a tape recording you
know and i had a tape deck by my side if
you look at like really old footage of
the disney animators they had record
players wow
which is nuts and they would like play
the piece of music over and over
and uh then you film your animation
and then you would bring in your bit of
music and then you'd play back the
animation for the director
and you'd get to watch the animation all
of that is a thousand times easier now
because
you have one program that's crazy like
you know we'll work on a project you
know like okay we have 40 effect shots
you break down our spreadsheet it's like
40 shots that's a lot i can't imagine
having a film broken out by
frames for every second there's 24
things you got to deal with and then
that goes on for however many minutes of
film you have
when i was at cal arts this short had
come out called family dog and it just
rocked my socks
and it turned out it was directed by a
young guy named brad bird who went to
cal arts and later on went on to do
little movies called
incredibles and ratatouille he loved
looking at life and you want to
incorporate as much of your observation
from real life into your animation
because when you have that kind of
observation it
grounds the animation and makes them
relatable
you're looking for something unusual
this also goes into live action
you know the most memorable live-action
performances you can think of it's not
them doing
a robotic or simple action it's always
that weird little thing that they add in
and it makes a moment memorable and so
when you have an animated scene
and the character does something in a
memorable odd way
it just comes to life if you guys have
other animations that you'd love to have
us
showcase here on the show please leave a
comment down below it's great
inspiration and
we'll see if we can keep doing some more
of these it's a really fun little twist
in the formula
guys we've talked about a lot of stuff
today
so let's combine all those things
together and talk about
one of my favorite movies of
spider-verse
when i first got into animation i would
see something that would really inspire
me and i would leave the theater shaking
and
you know as i've gotten older maybe a
little more jaded i'd kind of lost a
little bit of that
rawness and then i went and saw this
movie and
got it again
they took advantage of the entire medium
there's elements of 2d animation 3d
animation
cinematic staging comic book staging
they did it all they
told a beautiful story
all right time to swing just like this
sequence is
quite famous miles is moving on twos
because he's
awkward he's inexperienced whereas peter
parker
is moving on once because he can control
it he's smooth
so film runs at 24 frames a second in
animation
you normally can animate things on twos
so any of the classic disney movies to
scooby-doo or whatever is generally
animated on two because you really can
do
12 drawings a second on rare occasions
they like to animate things on ones
so as miles gains control of his skills
he starts to move on once there you go
now he's
working on ones and he's gaining the
smoothness it was a
insider animation trick but it made you
feel
the weight of it
the other thing i would talk about is
just the posing of this movie they're
using the john kirby posing
you know he used forced perspective to
give motion in his comic books because
you know he only had still drawings but
here they have the animation but they're
incorporating that really dynamic posing
to remind you that this is a comic book
the other element to talk about is the
hand-drawn elements over the characters
they did the cg
then the scene was brought into a
hand-drawn animation program and he or
she is going in and drawing the little
nose lines and all of that frame by
frame so it's combining the 2d and
3d to really like i said take full
advantage of the medium yeah the style
is just
so cool and feels so fresh they're doing
a second one aren't they they are
they're working on it right now as i
understand
[Music]
hey everyone it's time in the video
where i tell you about today's sponsor
draftkings now i know draftkings is
about sports and that doesn't have
anything to do with animators react but
hey whatever the playoffs are coming up
in october and
football is starting september 10th so i
gotta call the guys and let them know
everything that draftkings has to offer
for sports this
september let's go
[Music]
hey nico what's up did you know that
draftkings is back
for this september with the return of
football and they've got a whole bunch
of prizes for sports fans because
like did you i mean i don't know what's
gonna happen with the bucks this year i
mean they got brady and gronk what do
you think about that
i mean as long as they throw the ball
along and make a good effort to run the
ball to like
to the goals i think they'll they got
what it takes you know it really just
comes down to
that these boys can put their mind where
the ball is
hey what's up man hey nick guess what
what what what what's going on man
draftkings is giving away
up to a hundred million dollars in total
prizes to people this year with one
lucky winner who is going to walk away
with a million dollars did you know that
sports is back
hey ren there's all these things you can
do in the lobby create
your own drafts you can create your own
teams you can create your own rosters
i like basketball it's my favorite sport
where can i access all this information
so draftkings it's free to sign up for
new users you can just click the link in
the description below or you can go to
draftkings.com and use
the code corridor crew to sign up
what's up clinton jones
draftkings.com use promo code corridor
crew i gotta go
what is going on so perfect i've let all
the guys know
we're gonna take our shot anyway if you
guys are interested head on over to
draftkings.com and use the promo code
coral crew it actually is the best way
to engage in sports uh
beyond just watching see you guys out
there hey if you guys enjoyed hearing
about animation on today's episode then
go ahead and subscribe because we got
more coming we also have the vfx artist
react series
and the summon react series we got a
whole lot of educational stuff for you
guys so subscribe
well that was really cool it's it's been
really neat to have some insight on an
art form that's been really important to
my life
really important to your life and
obviously important to your life as well
we'll put a link down in the description
below to eric's channel if you want to
go check it out
and thank you so much for for actually
for giving us the idea for this show
thank you so much it's really cool to
take that initiative yeah and thank you
guys you know i love
love your series it's really fun to
watch really inspiring
big thank you to you guys as well man
well i really appreciate that
big thanks all around and thank you to
you guys for watching and hope to see
you in the next one